here's the latest target for retribution
by the foaming elites
patriotic americans this democrat says
we must be suspicious of the national
guard
you know because they're dudes and stuff
the guard
is 90 some odd percent i believe
male 1 um only about
20 of white males voted for bible
they're probably not more than 25
of the people that are there protecting
us who voted for biden the other 75
percent
are in the class that would be the the
large class of folks
who might want to uh do something
probably racist so where might this
political vetting of the military lead
will republicans be court-martialed or
will biden build an
army within an army isn't this what they
expected from trump
meanwhile there's this widespread video
meant to instigate reprisals against
yes trump's secret army in the years
ahead trump will lead his army of
domestic terrorists
he will encourage and incite violence he
will play the role of arsonist and
firemen he will start a civil war and
then say things were more peaceful when
he was president
we have to fight back he's going to be
out of office they can't let him go
so won't that video lead to more
violence targeting trumpers
but hey i'm not gonna blame a video for
violence only the democrats do that
remember the same people blaming you for
the capital violence are the same people
who blame you
for the summer's violence and are the
same people who blamed
benghazi on a video yeah laugh it's
funny
but it's happening again the targeting
of dissent by labeling words as crimes
so they could be silenced but americans
get it elite approved violence never
matters the summer's violence
it was nothing but your vote well that
makes you the clan
democratic cities are in chaos right now
is this what you want from joe biden and
they're going to take your country away
and they're taking down the statues i'm
never on the side
of the klan i am not principal people
conservative or
liberal never on the clan side principal
people conservative or liberal
never on the nazi side principal people
who are conservative
or liberal never on the side
that treats their their fellow americans
as less than
that says that your fellow americans
should not exist
judging everybody by their worst element
now when you bring up this contrast you
get accused of what about
ism but that's all history is one long
what about ism
in which the idiots of today are often
idiots of the past
hence the need to hide behind feeble
dismissals
but we aren't comparing actions just the
response to said actions
which is the only way to keep people
accountable could the media's defense of
mob action
allow for more in the future as they
come for you
right now we have a salivating lynch mob
formed from the press
academia big tech the dc power structure
linking commentary to crime in order to
drive censorship
harassment and boycotts ultimately
arrests may come
with 74 million domestic terrorists
we better get started all right i want
to go to dana bash
first um it's kind of weird uh
how the democrats ms bash are
scared of their own troops i mean what
does that
say well i think
that a couple things i was listening to
this podcast where they said that
each group republicans democrats
conservative liberals
think that they are losing in the battle
okay so like democrats even though they
now have the both the house and the
senate and the white house they still
think
that they are losing the battle
republicans think
that they have loss of battle but just a
couple of things to remind this is a
list jesse here's a list for you
um republicans held the democrats to the
narrowest minority possible in the
senate okay we see that
50 50. that is the you can't get more
narrow than that
um we have a majority of governor's
mansions that are now republican
a majority of state legislatures are
republicans that means redistricting
and a six three majority on the supreme
court and
republicans were said there to lose the
house they were going to lose more seats
in the senate and they didn't do that
so i think that you know i think that
when you have a fringe
um and criminals that did certain things
to suggest that that is
broad brush and paints all 74 million
people that voted for president trump
with the same brush that obviously is
not good
and not true and not fair remember that
the media spent a long time
after the 2016 election going all around
the country saying who are these voters
um well they're the same voters um there
were terrible people
that had horrible actions at the capitol
just up the street here
um that does not mean 74 million
americans are the same
yeah i think the two solutions to
healing this country
is assuming the best and the people you
disagree with not
assuming the worst and i think i forgot
the second point
i think the second point was even better
than the first point jesse
well first of all thank you for your
strong defense of what about ism
that definitely needed to be said um but
when you when you see 25 000
national guardsmen in washington dc a
lot of people
feel that might just be a political show
of force especially
when you hear the department of defense
saying there is no intelligence
to indicate that there is any threat at
all and there's not even going to be a
crowd because of kovid tomorrow
and you're hearing reports that a lot of
the guardsmen don't even have
bullets in the chamber they're just
walking around unarmed so
i do believe you got to beef up security
in the capitol after
the mob attack on the capitol i do agree
with that
but it seems a little bit overkill are
they doing that because they're paranoid
or are they doing that
to inflate the threat
from innocent trump supporters to
justify
the crackdown i don't know the
congressman should be ashamed of himself
to to accuse the the american national
guard of plotting an assassination
attempt
because they're white male by the left
standards he should be canceled and the
fact that the cnn guy just stared there
and blinked at him
was atrocious and to make matters worse
he even got the exit polls wrong and
that was really makes me upset
biden won 40 of white male voters not 20
percent
so this country has to stop acting like
communist china where we're going to
persecute political dissidents because
of what they tweet
i mean that is more of a threat than a
few
crazy people storming the capital long
term
yeah you know uh uh just juan jesse
makes a good point oddly
uh that um if you just if you were to
apply
cohen's uh ideas to like let's say a
different race
that the assumption that a certain group
of people act a certain way
he would be toast but it's okay cause
they're just white males and
white males are evil as you know because
you work with them
juan well thank you thank you thank you
mr what about
uh i would say that this is not what
about here i think that uh congressman's
cohen's comments were way over the top
i don't think that you can make a
judgment uh
about people's ability to do their job
on the basis of their political beliefs
i just think that's wrong and i think it
invites the kind of thinking that greg
is leading us to but i will say this in
all fairness that just today
in the news it says that 12 members of
the national guard
were found to have ties to extremists
and removed from the group here in
washington so
it's not to say that this is alarmism it
is to say that a small very small number
given the high number of
national guard troops on the ground here
in d.c uh were found to have some
extremist ties and as you know the
pentagon last week
had to send out an alarm in a sense
saying to
everyone you know what we are here to
defend the constitution
no matter what your political beliefs
may be
and that's why i think today you had
mitch mcconnell the senate majority
leader saying yes
president trump provoked that mob and
yes other
important powerful people in washington
added to that
that was a mistake and he acknowledged
it the uh
katie uh juan just heated up for you
these uh basically they said you should
defend the constitution no matter what
your political beliefs are
which is exactly why they shouldn't be
doing this to the national guardsmen
12 of them extremist extremist ties
what could that be well the pentagon the
pentagon also clarified and said that
not all of them had anything to do
with the capital in fact only two of
them did and my big question is
how are they determining what extremism
is how
what are they using as their their
barometer
for what counts as extremism if you
voted for trump as the democrat
cohen said or does it entail something
else what are they matching up against
and are we going to have the fbi which
has lost
a ton of trust with the american people
in terms of their own political biases
over the last six years
doing this but i just have to say i know
that i'm already on the list because i
named my dog gadsden
after the american revolution and now
they're trying to say that that's an
extremist thing to do
so poor gadsden he's already on the list
he's going to get canceled
even though he's really cute yeah the
only list i'm on is the
harry and david email list you buy one
thing from harry and david
and all they do is send emails i want
them to stop
sending me emails i buy one flower food
basket
that's all i want